continuing with the
exciting very exciting game number eight
and
yeah not much happened here like to say
that not much happened here is
well i'll i'll give it the best 10 15
minutes i can for this one but
anything above it will be
well abusing not my time but the viewers
time so
now
e4 excellent move
first first time by carlton that is
playing e4 and
as opposed to anand that is playing like
he has a plus two lead and needs
very few points to win the match
actually ben guess what carlson is
really in that situation yeah he is
really leading before this match four
and a half two and a half
and you know every draw is like you know
like a huge jump right it's like it's
not like half a point it's like
so
playing with white e4
i don't know if i'm
the world champ world champ you know
fighting for
survival
maybe sicilian something like that i
mean of course white has endless amount
of solid lines in whatever you want or
think of playing you want to play most
exciting sicilian okay bishop b5 check
some other solid lines okay
impossible to say hey blake needs to
play four we will play dragon okay
you're not gonna get the dragon
knight c6 is okay
but you know what you're going to get in
many position the possibility for some
game
something
so what does an end go
what
i mean
e5
i mean once again you know i feel kind
of kind of not okay you know i'm kind of
bad-mouthing the world champ or i mean i
i don't want to do that i don't think
i'm doing it i hope i'm not but
i say exactly what i see
and i see a world champ that kind of
like saying okay you know i don't care
i mean yeah okay it's much easier for me
i quoted kasparov because i said it
before and again so much respect to
anand i mean
and he deserves every every every bit of
respect but yet
yeah you know you basically see his
performance in the last five years
pretty much not winning anything major
someone someone had it uh
huh
no yeah yeah but but not games but like
tournaments like what did he win nothing
nada seriously like want some small
tournament in germany this year
and this is over five years someone said
look this is what you get
you have one player
carlos said pretty much dominated the
chess world
kasparov style
pretty much at any tournament and if not
winning
some big accident happened and he's
number two
and other hand you have anna that didn't
even get close to winning anything
oh you see it here so
well carlson is very cool i actually
like this line quite a lot rookie one
in 2010
this line became quite popular actually
because of the game
carlson against anand
played in nanjing
played in nanjing in 2010-10 the
tournament in china that carlson
won
and actually carlson got a winning
position against anand the game finished
in
the game finished in a draw
a month after it annan played it in the
london tournament against mcshane
but these days 2013 in 2010 okay there
was some
difficult or some ideas to create some
difficulties for black today
we all know it's pretty much nothing
actually in this building
in this building here in the beautiful
chess lab in st louis
two flows up
two flows up in the boardroom
believe it or not two months ago plus
few days
carlson played this position from the
black side against
icarua
and they played quite a long line
which led to a draw actually it was
important gaming a tournament because
icao played excellent tournament and was
almost
you know
decent chances or some chances to catch
to carlson
so everyone knows it and they are
getting pretty much
nothing
96 knight take e5
blocking
bishop beck
knight take the other main line is
knight to f5
and here actually the best move for
white or what is considered main move
for white is
knight
f3
basically kind of saying you know those
night
those knights
not in ideal squares they are both
targeting d4 but i'm going to play d4
this is how white is playing it's also
considered not much considered nothing
but
it's another version
at some point actually this was the more
popular version
take take i mean okay i can mention
games kashimov anand from nanjing 2010.
we mentioned carlos in an ant
from that tournament as well i'm going
to be careful with the mike you know
like
been reminding me yes justine
you beat him what what was the thymu
blades
very cool
okay
that
that cool enough
okay so
bishop f6 after
after d4
another line is 98 the knight is going
to move away from here so black can
get a pawn
and
rookie one
yeah
and here anand mcshane that we mentioned
95 was played
let's see what what is white's dream if
we can put it like that 92
the pawn on
d5 gives white tiny bit of
space
tiny bit of space
a4 actually very cool move
getting the rook in the game
this way very cool move
okay anand had some small advantage here
the game finished in a draw
very look the rook is controlling also
this one this is anand
mcshane from london 2010
let me i want to see if i can
find
you know let me go back just for a
second showing you the line that was
played here
once again we said we'll make effort to
give this one if we'll make it 20 25
minutes boom that's a amazing
amazing
knight c3 is something to consider we
basically want to go for the bishop
if white plays knight d5 and take
no okay
something
but this line is the one they play these
days and this one was played as i said
two months ago
two flows up
carlsen is black
what
yeah
and i think he carver played g3 now
why why is this you know usually you say
a pair of bishop self bishops any white
spell of bishops but
look at the black pawn chain
completing
the
color dominance with the dark color
bishop
so very pretty black has
bishop to control dark squares and the
pawns are controlling the light squares
for example if you take this bishop and
put it here of course white is better
okay how much here microscopically you
put it on computer i think zero two but
with zero two you're not beating magnus
carson you're not beating many many many
strong players with zero two
so this is one version
and this line is just just reasonable
this way or the other
believe it or not all this is big theory
like for example look they cook
how should black take after octi cook
night take
c3 d5
this was adam saronian nakamura kramnik
from 2013 adam saronian from london
2011.
not really that much here
c3
take take
all of this is theory all of this was
played
bishop d3
g6
i mean black
tiny less space you just need to
exchange some pieces i mean queen e7 was
a move played by
actually
peter nielsen honey peter nelson that is
connected to both players he was a nun
second for many many years and then he
was helping carson in the candidates and
in a very honorable way i think
put himself on the side for the match he
was
working for a nun for many years
then quit anand and kinda supported the
opponent in the candidates but when the
real match is coming
he didn't take a side i believe
um or at least possible this
impossibility he will be
joining carlson team
after the match
but for the match he put himself on the
side he played this line against mahmoud
of he's a huge divition this was played
in 2012.
okay actually white got tiny bit here
but
black still made a draw g6 is very
logical some ideas like from queen's
gamut the knight is making this maneuver
and the very big idea to
exchange
bishops okay we have game of nepalnyashi
reason 3 from 2011. so this position has
already been played you know all this
liquidation horizontalis
from montreal very recent tournament
2013
rookie one
bishop f5 yeah how how to make it more
exciting i don't know
okay knight back he wants to put the
knight here
bishop e5 okay here he'll come the big
big exciting moment of this game
take take no okay so technically maybe
white is zero one better or something
and
okay big moment white is pressuring
attacking
okay knight g7
with a tiny big idea okay that would
have made this
video much much more interesting if you
would have played these you would have
said the funniest most bizarre amazing
blunder in chess history
take
and write resigned
yeah
but like we said you know
gailfund was leading plus one against a
nun and immediately blundered
immediately after having a plus one lead
immediately blundered
carlsen just doesn't blunder that's the
thing
like he just
very very rarely in the game that he
loses
it looks like he just kind of wasn't
focused enough or maybe a tiny bit
stressed but
those positions it's just pretty much
like computer i mean just positional
play
so returning the ball not making a
mistake
and i mean it's kind of somewhat
depressing for chess well i think for
some for some players for some fans kind
of depressing but
you know at least he's a big hype so how
to make a door
queen takes the e8 of course queen take
is not so cool
but that is exactly the idea
and julian congratulations you managed
to exchange every possible piece on the
board against anand and make a door
and probably if you had played the match
you would have made the same thing so
it's no joke
no and this is beautiful they manage
they manage wow look at that what can
you say
absolutely symmetrical position on move
34
that's why they are the best players in
the world
so
i don't know what else can we speak
about anything interesting in sport or
something
if not then
well next game starting in
seven and a half hours
i can tell you the most interesting
thing is that i've been awaking at those
hours whether it was a rest day or not
like the most fascinating thing i woke
up at 3 30 00 on the rest day without
alarm clock
one day i woke up 329 one day 350.
just you know i just need some sleep so
they should finish this match
anyway so really
maybe it will be nice to all of us
to see games nine and ten much more
interesting and maybe maybe maybe you
know if anand will win something
i will come here say wow i was wrong you
won a game
but i think everyone will be as excited
as humanly possible can you imagine if
anand wins the next two games
wow
but it would be best match in history
i think so yeah
i mean they should have stopped playing
many many games ago
this is my take right and obviously
obviously yes himself the world champion
and a team of
extremely strong grandmasters that is
playing e4
i just have a feeling that
it's not like
let's put it this way
the ability to kill the game and i'm
using that phrase kill the game
somewhat easier with e4 for black to
kill the game
as to d4 i mean in default yeah you can
tell me patronan
how do you get advantage against the
grunfeld
i don't
know many lines are extremely
interesting in 2010 the first game
topalov anand
they played super crazy complicated line
an unforgotten move order
they played 22 moves theory and
unforgotten switch moved was lost on
move twenty
three
so just blunted
how to get advantage against nimzo
indian
i don't know
but there are
so many interesting lines
so and those are top openings
maybe the
comparing the berlin i would say queen's
gambit
queen's gambit declined
but in queens can be declined it's
possible to play
i mean here
look at those two games white and black
the game was just killed killed nothing
nothing i mean you know
looking at the ceiling and
nothing staring at the ceiling it's not
like
there are different positions when
computers showing you 0 one minus zero
one
and that's a big game
night off dragon
all this position it's like
big big big heart attack
that's the problem and i thought that
anand should play d4
and
you know
ever since i played chess i always
always always had great respect to
stronger players than me it doesn't
matter he doesn't have to be world
champion for me too he can just be
stronger and master cause no i know that
i know that i worked hard to become an
okay grandmaster or something and most
likely is much better
but
something is wrong at least in my view
about those people like about
the way that the match is going from for
an ant and i say those people this team
well
maybe they can prove wrong tonight you
know they will prove everyone wrong in
their game i mean okay objectively i
think that that carlton would have won
the match doesn't matter what
the only thing is that
so what if an unwooden blunder in a
nakamura was online
live during the matches and he suggested
immediately the two moves that would
make doors in the in the games
so what if an android and blonder and
just play
like icarl which i think now is better
player than anand i had dinner yesterday
with some people i told him this i said
if nakamura would have played the match
four four
i mean okay take game three that's why
that anandos ma was better and gainful
that he blundered objectively four four
like he wouldn't lose any of those end
games he wouldn't have even problems
truth to be told
anand is great at his time play chess
for quarter of a century at the highest
level
it's probably not uh not what they used
to be
i i mean i think that 10 years ago we
would have made easy 10 15 years ago
easy draws in those games we
wouldn't lose those he wouldn't he
shouldn't
couldn't
let's say that you come now and say
ronan
i heard what you're saying for two weeks
about the match about this what what
should i play
i'll tell him to play d4 with white and
try some lines in sicilian with c5 look
at some bishop b5
probably it's not going to change the
result but at least it will be a better
effort
you